anderson police investigating an early  morning officer-involved shooting it  happened near east lake mead and  burkholder we've got a live picture here  at the scene nearby so we can take that  for you  you can see a lot of activity police say  that they got a call about a suspicious  person that was attempting to break into  vehicles when officers got there the man  ran off this is earlier video here  during the pursuit officers say the man  allegedly pulled out a gun which  prompted them to fire hitting him police  say they now believe the weapon was a  replica bb gun but they need to  investigate a little bit more the  suspect was hospitalized but is expected  to recover